Gandhi Eleanor Roosevelt Nelson Mandela
Henry Ford these are leaders who trusted
their inner voice
oh you've got to be kidding me
thod Quest is way better off without
them damn straight this is our
masterpiece
mq's doing well I know you guys didn't
think I could do it no no we I mean we
literally haven't said your name in a
year oh I'd like to introduce you to our
newest employee I'm glad you're back you
know it's janitor I see a lot of things
but you have nothing to worry about
there's nothing like strange or
nefarious going on that's some
Illuminati and even if there was you'd
never know it
um sorry wait what he's always wanted to
bring mq to Hollywood but I'm the first
one to pull it off how could I not even
be consultant on my DNA is literally all
over that game
No One's Gonna believe that he could
play me he's not big enough he's like
six four six five six five
you have made a huge mistake I am
Elizabeth Graham I'm building an entire
game from scratch and you're pacing
around to metaphors
I totally got it I had to work with
those wackos too
banana
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
just be a normal person and just take
notes on your phone because like a
normal person I lost my phone ages ago
and now Dana takes my calls for me don't
nobody call you
[Music]